No podemos modificar muchos de los eventos
que acabo de mencionar; pues son inevitables,
como la cesárea que fue inventada para salvar vidas,
y eso se hace a diario.
Y la mayoría de los medicamentos se prescriben por una razón,
especialmente en el caso de infantes.
Por ello debemos aprender a salvaguardar la salud de estos bebés
luego de esos eventos que se dan tempranamente
y que pueden desajustar el desarrollo de la microbiota intestinal,
Trabajo como investigadora
y como encargada de un equipo de salud infantil.
La pregunta que intentamos contestar en nuestro trabajo,
y la misma pregunta que intento responder en esta charla,
es cómo podemos asegurarnos
de que todos los bebés tengan las mismas oportunidades de gozar de buena salud,
sin importar cómo nacieron o cuáles fueron sus circunstancias tempranas.
Es una causa noble, ¿no?
Ahora bien, contestemos esta pregunta.
¿Recuerdan que mencioné que se necesita la combinación exacta de microbios?
Pues bien, para tenerla
necesitamos adquirir esos microbios que residen en el organismo
en un determinado orden.
Pueden considerarlo como una campaña de colonización.
Los primeros microbios que residen en el organismo
alteran el entorno de la microbiota intestinal del infante
para que así los próximos microbios sean capaces de entrar.
Algo así como los primeros invasores
que llegan antes e instalan la infraestructura
sobre la cual los colonos continúan la construcción.
Si los bebés nacen por cesárea,
esa primera fase de colonización se ve drásticamente alterada,
pues en lugar de las bacterias vaginales, fecales y epiteliales de la madre,
solamente las bacterias epiteliales
ingresan a la microbiota intestinal del infante.
Esto hace que la campaña de colonización tenga un ritmo totalmente diferente,
y simplemente por tratarse de algo distinto
a lo que nos hemos adaptado evolutivamente
podría causar algunas desventajas
en términos de salud para los bebés nacidos por cesárea.
Podemos tomar como ejemplo el desarrollo del peso.
Varios estudios ya han demostrado
que la composición de la microbiota intestinal se relaciona con el peso
y con la probabilidad de desarrollar enfermedades
como la diabetes o de tipo cardiovascular.
Pero ahora hay algunos indicadores que permiten observar durante la infancia,
a partir de una muestra fecal del bebé,
algunos microbios ausentes en estos individuos
que más adelante desarrollan obesidad o sobrepeso.
También se ha demostrado que esos mismos microbios
pueden estar ausentes en bebés nacidos por cesárea
o con predisposición a necesitar
muchos antibióticos en los primeros meses de vida.
Y para cerrar esta idea,
también se ha demostrado en algunos estudios
que los bebés nacidos por cesárea,
o a quienes se les prescribe muchos antibióticos a una edad temprana,
son más propensos a padecer obesidad o sobrepeso, incluso en un 50 %,
que es mucho.
Sé que ahora deben estar pensando:
"Oh, no, hace poco tuve una cesárea", "Yo nací por cesárea"
o "Mi hijo toma antibióticos".
Pero no quiero que se preocupen.
Si estos microbios están ausentes por cualquier motivo,
pueden adquirirse más adelante.
Pero el bebé necesitará algo de ayuda para ello.
Se sabe desde hace tiempo que amamantar ayuda.
La leche materna es casi milagrosa: además de tener nutrientes para el bebé,
aparentemente también tiene alimento para los microbios buenos.
Eso es muy beneficioso para los bebés que son amamantados,
pero sabemos que no todos los bebés lo son.
¿Qué podemos hacer para garantizar que los bebés que no son amamantados
puedan restaurar el desarrollo de su microbiota
después de experimentar esos eventos negativos a una edad temprana
que pueden desajustar el desarrollo de su microbiota intestinal?
Ahora llegamos a la parte de la charla que tiene las soluciones.
La investigación en este campo ha avanzado muchísimo últimamente.
Primero, se comprendió que si nos faltan algunos microbios,
podemos ingerirlos.
Denominamos "probióticos" a los microbios "buenos" que podemos ingerir.
Estos probióticos han sido estudiados en varios ensayos clínicos durante años,
e incluso en infantes se han observado importantes efectos,
como la reducción del riesgo de tener eczema.
Una segunda revolución se dio
cuando los investigadores se focalizaron en la leche materna.
Fue lógico ya que, como mencioné,
ya se sabía que la lactancia contribuye al desarrollo sano
de la microbiota intestinal.
La leche materna tiene unas partículas
que se descubrieron ya en la década de 1930.
Se llaman "oligosacáridos de la leche humana",
pero se desconocía su función,
y esta ignorancia duró décadas tras su descubrimiento inicial.
Resultaba ser un gran misterio para los investigadores,
pues son verdaderamente abundantes en la leche materna.
De hecho, son el tercer grupo más numeroso de sólidos,
pero no son digeribles para los humanos, ni siquiera para los infantes.
¿Por qué las madres sintetizarían algo en la leche materna
que usa recursos pero que no es utilizable para los infantes?
La naturaleza no suele funcionar de esa forma.
Por lo que fue una gran revelación cuando finalmente se comprendió
cuál es la función de estas partículas:
alimentar de forma selectiva
a los microbios que son buenos para los infantes,
y de esa manera impactar en su salud.
Existen más de cientos de estructuras de oligosacáridos
y en la actualidad podemos sintetizar algunas en el laboratorio.
Esto nos permite empaquetarlas
junto con los probióticos para el consumo de niños e infantes
que no las recibieron de la lactancia
y esto restaura la microbiota intestinal
después de experimentar eventos negativos tempranamente.
A esa solución hemos llegado.
Como investigadora, debo admitir
que los estudios en este campo continúan en proceso
y que aún queda mucho trabajo por realizar.
A los científicos nos encanta afirmar eso.
Pero estamos dando los primeros pasos para comprender mejor
cuáles son los microbios clave faltantes en varias situaciones
y qué oligosacáridos deberíamos empaquetar con los probióticos
para ayudar a restaurar la microbiota de un bebé determinado
en una situación determinada.
Lo que deseo que recuerden de esta charla
es que efectivamente los bebés que nacen por parto natural y son amamantados
poseen la microbiota que necesitamos.
Pero en los casos en que esas condiciones no se dan,
existen medidas para reducir las consecuencias negativas en la salud.
Por último, quiero que imaginen un mundo
en el que exista un sistema de salud
en que al llevar a un bebé a los controles rutinarios de salud,
se controle también el desarrollo de la microbiota intestinal de ese bebé
y, si se detecta una deficiencia,
se prescriba un producto especialmente diseñado para restaurar la microbiota.
¿No sería espectacular
si el inicio de enfermedades crónicas fuese algo extremadamente inusual
debido a un sistema de salud preventivo?
¿Pueden imaginar un mundo así?
¿Creen que un futuro así sea posible?
Yo sí.
Creo en ese futuro y quiero contribuir a la realización de ese futuro:
un futuro en que cada bebé tenga el mismo punto de partida
para una buena salud durante el resto de su vida.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)